we are now three weeks on from the death
of George Floyd and national
demonstrations do not appear to be
slowing down tens of thousands of people
turned out for peaceful protests in
cities and towns all across the country
this comes as new video emerges of
Floyd's deadly encounter with police and
a warning you're now familiar with this
is difficult to watch Jeff buguese is
outside Atlanta Police Headquarters with
more Jeff good morning what kind of
change do protestors want well we talked
to the president of the Georgia State
n-double-a-cp he is calling for a
culture shift in police and one that
protects citizens first and he's also
endorsing the idea of shifting funding
from police or the community in fact
that's something that we heard across
the country and in Minneapolis a city
that is still dealing with the
aftershocks of George Floyd's death the
man he moves at bro disturbing new video
George Floyd's death in Minneapolis this
video released by the fluid family
attorney shows bystanders begging with
police to stop when they see that Floyd
isn't moving or more officer Derek
Chauvin was charged with second-degree
murder in Floyd's death
well three other officers were charged
with aiding and abetting the revolution
is here large protests over police
brutality and racial injustice are
continuing across the country in Seattle
demonstrators are holding up in several
blocks near a downtown police station
and what they are calling an autonomous
zone black lives matter the protesters
are demanding broad reforms in the wake
of Floyd's death I can't
the police shooting of Rashard Brooks
was also captured on cameras from
multiple angles in Atlanta the shooting
drew condemnation from the Georgia
n-double-a-cp
and its president Reverend James major
Woodall we can sum it up in four words
that we are done dying he is calling for
an overhaul of policing and state
funding to be diverted to community
programs
the problem is white supremist the
dehumanization of communities that we
live in this is about accountability its
systemic pain
Vince champion southeast regional
director for the union representing the
Atlanta officers believes there is room
for changes in policing but says city
officials should have waited before
firing the officer who shot and killed
Brooks should it have ended that way no
we never want anyone to lose their life
all right so clearly something went
wrong no no clearly something went wrong
and you can't say that the evidence
takes us there because we're not done
with the evidence yet if you look at the
race yard Brooks tape you may be
wondering especially if you know a
little bit about police tactics could
the officers have de-escalated the
situation and the union right now is
saying that because it happened so
quickly going from zero to 100 the
officers did not have a chance to
de-escalate and that's why they are
cautioning the public to withhold
judgment at this time and just wait for
the investigation to play out
Gail Jeff how many more of these stories
do we have to report you raised a lot of
good questions and a lot of people want
answers to those questions thank you
very much